So, you consider yourself to be something
of a movie buff, do you?
You may know the entire script of The Goonies
word-for-word, you might know which actors
portrayed every single character in the Harry
Potter franchise, and you might even know
which year every movie in the Friday the 13th
franchise was released, but what about those
lesser known facts from behind the scenes?There
are a lot of facts about movies that might
just take you by surprise - and that's what
this video is all about.
Here's our latest edition of twenty rapid
fire behind the scenes movie facts...
Captain America: Civil War
The working title of Captain America: Civil
War was actually "Sputnik".
In the comic books, "Sputnik" was one of the
words used to trigger the Winter Soldier's
mind control.
Thor: Ragnarok
Thor: Ragnarok will bring to life a loose
adaptation of the acclaimed comic book arc
Planet Hulk, and will see Thor and Hulk squaring
off against each other on a gladiatorial planet,
prior to teaming up to defeat the movie's
villains.
Transformers: Age of Extinction
In an interview about Transformers: Age of
Extinction, director Michael Bay described
the Autobot Hound as "a ballerina with guns".
This line actually became part of Hound's
dialogue in the movie.
Wolverine (Weapon X)
After 2016's Deadpool became such a huge success
in spite of it's "R" rating, Fox are intending
to make 2017's Wolverine movie R-rated as
well.
Bring on the gore!
Deadpool
Producer Simon Kinberg has said that Olivia
Munn auditioned for the role of Vanessa Carlysle
in Deadpool - a role that ultimately went
to Morena Baccarin.
However, Munn's audition led to her being
cast as Psylocke in X-Men: Apocalypse.
X-Men: Apocalypse
In X-Men: Apocalypse, the song playing in
the scene when Apocalyse finds Angel is by
the heavy metal band Metallica.
It's called "The Four Horsemen" from the album
"Kill 'Em All", which was released in 1983
- the same year in which the film takes place.
The Legend of Tarzan
Alexander Skarsgård was ultimately cast as
Tarzan in The Legend of Tarzan, but swimmer
Michael Phelps was actually in talks to take
on the role.
Fellow swimmer Johnny Weissmuller played the
character in the movies of the 1930s and 1940s.
The Amazing Spider-Man 2
You may recall the scene in The Amazing Spider-Man
2 in which Gwen Stacy gives a speech at her
graduation.
Well, actress Emma Stone actually wrote that
speech herself.
Spider-Man: Homecoming
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige will be working
as an Executive Producer on Spider-Man: Homecoming.
However, unlike when he works on other MCU
movies, Feige will not receive any compensation
for his role, due to the contract details
in the Marvel/Sony deal.
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story
John Williams has composed the score for every
Star Wars theatrical release to date, and
Rogue One will mark the first time in which
that won't be the case.
Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman will meet her love interest Steve
Trevor in her first solo movie.
In the comic books, they met during World
War II.
In the movie, they will meet in World War
I.
The idea is to highlight her immortality more
explicitly.
Zootopia
In Zootopia, there's a nudist Indian Yoga
instructor working at Mystic Springs Oasis
named Nangi.
In India, Nangi refers to a naked woman in
the Hindi language.
Maleficent
Lana Del Rey sang "Once Upon a Dream" for
the end credits of Maleficent.
Del Rey was personally picked by the movie's
star, Angelina Jolie, for the job of doing
so.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
Jeffrey Dean Morgan - who had previously played
the Comedian in Watchmen - played Bruce Wayne's
Wayne's father Thomas in Batman v Superman,
but he was actually considered for the role
of Bruce Wayne AKA Batman himself.
The Martian
One of the key plot elements in The Martian
is the force of the wind on Mars.
It is shown as being strong enough to topple
a large rocket and carry big objects.
In reality, the atmosphere there is so thin,
even the fastest wind would feel like a breeze
to humans.The Jungle Book
In King Louie's temple in the new Jungle Book
movie, one of the many treasures he has in
his possessions happens to be the Genie's
lamp from Aladdin, another Disney movie.
Warcraft
In spite of its extremely mixed critical reviews,
with huge takings of $8.5 million, Warcraft
has recently the record for the largest weekday-midnight
opening in China.
Avengers: Age of Ultron
For Age of Ultron, in order to make the Scarlet
Witch's movements look more graceful in action
sequences, actress Elizabeth Olsen worked
with a dance choreographer.
Suicide Squad
Although Margot Robbie looks fantastic as
Harley Quinn in Suicide Squad, Emma Roberts
was actually offered the role first.
However, she turned it down to star in television's
Scream Queens.
Suicide Squad
In order to transform Akinnuoye-Agbaje into
Killer Croc, Suicide Squad's make-up team
took five hours to apply prosthetics to his
face and upper body.
The rest was body paint.
Thanks for watching our list of 20 rapid fire
behind the scenes movie facts.
Did you know about any of these?
Which other great movie facts do you know
of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.